It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务正在快速扩张。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有顶级优先数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使在蜂巢最繁忙的时候，我的连接依然稳固。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这可是个难得的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐吧。另需缴纳税费和政府费用。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Is everyone talking about you behind your back? Is your co-worker trying to undermine you? Why are you always afraid that something bad is going to happen? For years, paranoia was seen as a symptom of severe mental illness, but in recent decades, some psychologists have begun to think about it differently. They've found that paranoid thoughts are relatively common, that there are links between paranoia and other forms of mistrust and anxiety,
Google Fi Wireless 在网络高负载时段不会降低数据流量优先级。大家是不是都在背后议论你？你的同事是不是在试图暗算你？为什么你总是担心会有坏事发生？多年来，偏执一直被视为严重精神疾病的症状，但近几十年来，一些心理学家开始以不同的方式看待它。他们发现偏执想法相对普遍，偏执与其它形式的不信任和焦虑之间存在联系，
and that there are therapeutic treatments that can help. So what are the causes of paranoia? Is paranoia and mistrust more generally becoming more common? Where is the line between a healthy level of skepticism and mistrust and problematic paranoia? What's the link between paranoia and anxiety? Or paranoia and schizophrenia? And what help is available for those suffering from paranoia in its more severe or mild forms? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association
并且有一些治疗方法可以提供帮助。那么，偏执的原因是什么？偏执和不信任是否变得越来越普遍了？健康的怀疑、不信任与有问题的偏执之间的界限在哪里？偏执与焦虑之间有什么联系？或者偏执与精神分裂症之间呢？对于那些遭受轻度或重度偏执困扰的人，有哪些帮助？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，
that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Daniel Freeman, chair of psychology at the University of Oxford and a consultant clinical psychologist in the Oxford Health NHS Foundation Trust. He leads the Oxford Cognitive Approaches to Psychosis Research Group and is one of the world's leading experts on paranoia. His book, Paranoia, A Journey into Extreme Mistrust and Anxiety, was published in the UK in 2024.
旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯。今天的嘉宾是牛津大学心理学系主任、牛津健康国民保健署基金会信托的临床心理学顾问丹尼尔·弗里曼博士。他领导着牛津认知精神病研究小组，是全球领先的偏执研究专家之一。他的著作《偏执：深入极端不信任与焦虑的旅程》于 2024 年在英国出版。
The U.S. edition comes out in March. Dr. Freeman, thank you for joining me today. Delighted to be here, Kim. I'd like to start, as we often do on this podcast with a definition. How do you define paranoia in your work? Principally, it's when you think others are trying to harm you in some way. when they're not. So it's inaccurate fear that others are deliberately trying to harm you. So you may fear they're trying to cause you psychological harm to distress you or financial harm or even physical
美国版将于三月发行。弗里曼博士，感谢您今天参加我们的节目。很高兴来到这里，金。我想像往常一样，从定义开始。在您的工作中，您是如何定义偏执的？主要来说，就是当你认为别人在某种程度上试图伤害你，而事实并非如此。所以这是一种认为别人故意伤害你的错误恐惧。你可能担心他们试图在心理上伤害你、让你痛苦，或者造成经济损失，甚至身体
harm. And there's a whole spectrum of severity of it in the general population and it often builds upon what we call ideas of reference when you think others are talking about you behind your back or spreading messages, and it also builds often upon a sort of sense of yourself being a bit vulnerable to harm from other people. How is it diagnosed? I mean, how do we know when it's reached a clinical level? So at the severe end, the most common form is what's called a persecutory delusion, and that's when we're very sure in our beliefs about what's going on.
伤害。在普通人群中，偏执存在一个严重程度的谱系，它通常建立在我们所说的“参照观念”之上，即你认为别人在背后议论你或散布消息，它也往往建立在一种认为自己容易受到他人伤害的脆弱感之上。它是如何被诊断的？我的意思是，我们怎么知道它何时达到了临床水平？在严重的一端，最常见的形式被称为“被害妄想”，即我们对正在发生的事情深信不疑。
So we might be convinced that there are people out there trying to kill us, for example, will take us hostage or try to get us out of the neighborhood. It's where we believe it strongly. Also, when we think about it a lot and it causes us distress. I mean, in essence, it's when it causes disruption to life. And the disruption typically becomes anxiety and depression and when we're responding to a way when we're typically avoiding things that are important meaning for another lives.
所以我们可能会确信有人想杀我们，或者会把我们扣为人质，或者试图把我们赶出社区。这是我们深信不疑的情况。此外，当我们过多地思考它并因此感到痛苦时。我的意思是，本质上，当它导致生活受到干扰时。这种干扰通常表现为焦虑和抑郁，当我们以某种方式做出反应，通常是回避生活中重要且有意义的事情时。
Now, we all have a little bit of suspicion, I think, at various times. times in our life. I'm just wondering how common are paranoid thoughts in the general population, and what about a clinical level of paranoia in the general population? We do all have it, and it's perfectly natural because all of us have to make a judgment about whether to trust or mistrust other people, because there are real dangers out there. So there is an element of risk estimation. Paranoia is when it's become overly weighted to mistrust and to such a strong degree, that we're feeling unsafe most of the time. The way I put it is that many people have a few paranoid thoughts,
现在，我想我们每个人在人生的不同阶段都会有一点怀疑。我只是想知道，偏执想法在普通人群中有多普遍？普通人群中达到临床水平的偏执又如何呢？我们确实都有这种想法，这是非常自然的，因为我们所有人都必须判断是否信任他人，因为现实中确实存在危险。所以这其中包含风险评估的成分。偏执是指当这种不信任感变得过重，以至于我们大部分时间都感到不安全。我的表达方式是：许多人会有一些偏执的想法，
a few people have many. When it's the level of a persecuted delusion, that's often in presentation of severe mental health problems. This often occurs in people who might receive a diagnosis of psychosis, such as schizophrenia, but there's a large proportion of the population to get paranoid thoughts and a large proportion you want help for it, who feel that it's got too much.
少数人会有很多。当它达到被害妄想的程度时，通常表现为严重的心理健康问题。这种情况常出现在可能被诊断为精神病（如精神分裂症）的人群中，但普通人群中有很大一部分人会有偏执想法，也有很大一部分人因为觉得难以承受而寻求帮助。
And what I should be very clear is that when there is actual threat out there, when there are real dangers of the person's perceiving, that's not paranoia, that's realistic threat perception. Paranoia is when it's just becoming excessive too much. And do we have any idea the percentage of people with a diagnosable level of paranoia? We're in the small percentages for that. So probably around one or two percent. But in terms of the general population, somewhere at least in our, we did a survey of
我需要明确一点，当现实中确实存在威胁，当一个人感知到真实的危险时，那不是偏执，那是现实的威胁感知。偏执是指这种感知变得过度、过分了。我们是否知道达到可诊断偏执水平的人群百分比？这个比例很小。大概在 1% 到 2% 左右。但就普通人群而言，至少在我们的调查中，我们对
UK adults, about 10,000 a representative sample, and around 16% were saying they would like help to be more trusting of other people. So it arises out of a very important psychological process we all have to think about about trust. And it's hard sometimes to know where to set the balance. And when we get it consistently wrong, that's paranoia. But, you know, with all this risk judgment, we need to be flexible. it's going to vary where we live, the neighborhood, time of day, a whole range of factors.
约 10,000 名英国成年人进行了代表性样本调查，大约 16% 的人表示他们希望获得帮助，以便更信任他人。所以它源于我们每个人都必须思考的关于信任这一非常重要的心理过程。有时很难知道如何把握平衡。当我们持续出错时，那就是偏执。但是，你知道，面对所有的风险判断，我们需要保持灵活性。它会根据我们居住的地方、社区、时间段以及一系列因素而变化。
So it's a process that we probably don't talk about enough with each other. Often we're just following what others around us are doing. But sometimes the people, it's a process that becomes too unbalanced towards the mistrustful. What's the connection between paranoia and other mental illnesses? I mean, for example, I think that a lot of us have an image of people with schizophrenia also almost always. being paranoid. Is that the case? It's probably the most common sign of psychosis, or what's taken is a sign of psychosis. It's one of the most common. But it's raised in most mental health conditions, people, depression.
所以这是一个我们之间讨论得不够充分的过程。通常我们只是跟随周围人的做法。但有时，对于某些人来说，这个过程变得过于向不信任倾斜。偏执与其它精神疾病之间有什么联系？我的意思是，例如，我认为我们很多人都有这样一种印象：精神分裂症患者几乎总是偏执的。是这样吗？这可能是精神病最常见的迹象，或者被认为是精神病的迹象。它是最常见的迹象之一。但它在大多数心理健康状况中都会出现，比如抑郁症。
In fact, some of the first historical accounts of paranoia talked about in the context of depression and anxiety disorders, but it cuts across. And certainly some of the data we have is that for many mental health conditions, when there is also paranoia in the picture, that is often an indication that things might persist a bit longer. And that's mainly because it often corrods social relationships. And then when they go a little bit wrong, that's not good for psychological health in general. So it's certainly at the severe end most commonly seen in severe mental health conditions, such as schizophrenia, but you can also sit in presentations of PTSD and depression and anxiety.
事实上，一些关于偏执的最早历史记录是在抑郁症和焦虑症的背景下讨论的，但它跨越了多种疾病。当然，我们掌握的一些数据表明，对于许多心理健康状况，当同时出现偏执时，这通常预示着病情可能会持续更久。这主要是因为它经常腐蚀社会关系。当关系出现问题时，这对整体心理健康是不利的。所以，它在严重的一端最常见于精神分裂症等严重心理健康状况中，但你也可以在创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）、抑郁症和焦虑症的表现中看到它。
And a lot of my work actually, when I came to it back in the 1990s, it was only thought really to occur with people with psychosis. and I remember one of the first people I met, it fitted so much with just having a very bad experience as people who treated them very badly. And there were so many overlaps with presentations of anxiety disorders that it really started to make me think, actually, this is much more understandable than it needs to be thought. But also there's so many connections to other mental health conditions. And then my career has gone on, and when you look for it, much more in the general population, it's there at rather high amounts. because it arises out of processes that were all judgments that we already have to make. So once you actually assess for it in the population, it's present. What do we know at this point about the causes of paranoia?
事实上，我在 20 世纪 90 年代刚开始工作时，人们认为它只发生在精神病患者身上。我记得我见过的第一个人，他的情况完全符合那种因为被他人恶劣对待而产生的糟糕经历。它与焦虑症的表现有太多重叠之处，这让我开始思考，实际上，这比人们想象的要容易理解得多。而且它与其它心理健康状况也有很多联系。随着我的职业生涯发展，当你去寻找它时，你会发现它在普通人群中的存在量相当高。因为它源于我们必须做出的判断过程。所以一旦你在人群中进行评估，它就会显现出来。目前我们对偏执的原因了解多少？
Is it something that is driven by life experiences? Is there a genetic component to it? Is it a combination of those things? We've made huge leaps, I think, in understanding the causes of it. At the broad level you talked about the data we have is about, half of it might be down to the genes, at least across the population, half of the differences down to genes, half down to the environment. But at the psychological level, we know a lot.
它是受生活经历驱动的吗？有遗传因素吗？还是这些因素的结合？我认为我们在理解其成因方面取得了巨大的飞跃。在宏观层面，正如你所谈到的，我们掌握的数据显示，大约一半的原因可能归结于基因，至少在整个人群中，差异的一半归因于基因，另一半归因于环境。但在心理层面，我们了解得很多。
There are multiple factors that are tilting the balance towards mistrust. It may be because people have done bad things to you, so it's unsurprising. You're going to be extremely wary of other people. Sometimes actually people are worried about things they've done in the past. Sometimes it's pushed further a lot of mistrust because of people spending a lot of time worrying, rather engage in meaning of activities, self-esteem may be low, people may be having images of their head of what people that are doing to them, there may be discrimination to people that is partly driving this.
有多种因素正在使天平向不信任倾斜。这可能是因为别人对你做过坏事，所以你非常警惕他人并不奇怪。有时人们实际上是在担心自己过去做过的事情。有时，由于人们花费大量时间担忧，而不是参与有意义的活动，导致不信任感进一步加剧；自尊心可能较低；人们脑海中可能浮现出别人正在对他们做什么的画面；部分原因是人们遭受的歧视。
For some people, they may be hearing voices that are telling them they're under threat. I could keep on going for quite a while. There's loads of things that can push people along, including some substances like cannabis, for example, there are many different factors. And in essence, the more that you have, have of these, the more likely it's going to push you further along the severity of the paranoia spectrum.
对一些人来说，他们可能听到有声音告诉他们正受到威胁。我可以继续列举很久。有很多事情可以推动人们，包括一些物质，比如大麻，有很多不同的因素。本质上，你拥有的这些因素越多，就越有可能将你推向偏执谱系的更严重一端。
Now, you've developed a treatment for paranoia and extreme mistrust that you call the Feeling safe program. Can you tell our listeners about that program and how it works? Yeah, so when I first trained as a clinical psychologist, my ambition was always to produce a much better psychological treatment for those conditions. And it used to be thought that you shouldn't talk about these experiences, people, and that they well, not really psychologically understandable. And then we had real progress in some early forms of cognitive behavior therapy
现在，您为偏执和极端不信任开发了一种治疗方法，您称之为“感觉安全”计划。您能向我们的听众介绍一下这个计划以及它是如何运作的吗？是的，当我最初接受临床心理学培训时，我的抱负一直是为这些疾病提供更好的心理治疗。过去人们认为不应该与患者谈论这些经历，认为它们在心理上是无法理解的。后来，我们在认知行为疗法（CBT）的早期形式中取得了真正的进展，
showed that it is safe and can help reduce paranoia. And then for me, it's about, well, what are the best psychological techniques to do this? At the broadest level, what you need to do to counter the feelings of mistrust and the people feeling unsafe is to help people learn that actually, at least now, that they are safe. And the best way to do that is to build up direct experience of that. So helping people go back into situations they feel unsafe in and actually learn that they are okay. But it's harder than that because there's a whole range of other things that are pulling the person into paranoia. I've listed some of them.
证明它是安全的，并且有助于减轻偏执。对我来说，关键在于：什么是实现这一目标的最佳心理技术？在最广泛的层面上，为了对抗不信任感和不安全感，你需要帮助人们认识到，至少在现在，他们是安全的。最好的方法是建立直接的体验。帮助人们回到他们感到不安全的处境中，并真正认识到他们是没问题的。但这比这更难，因为还有一系列其它因素将人拉向偏执。我已经列举了一些。
So even if you go into a situation that is safe, if you're in your mind as catastrophizing and worrying and feeling about how maybe you're inferior to others or vulnerable, you're not going to learn safety. So there's a whole range of other things we need to do to get the person in the right psychological state to experience the world are new and feel safe. So we help people worry less, we help people sleep better, we build up people self-confidence, and then we've got a person to the best psychological state, we then do this direct learning of safety in the world. And that builds up a much more dominant view of the world as safe. And one of the important things to know in this approach is that what we don't really do in our treatment is going, telling the person they're wrong, or challenging their existing position. We're setting out an alternative description of what they be going on.
所以，即使你进入了一个安全的处境，如果你的内心在灾难化、担忧，并感到自己可能不如他人或很脆弱，你就无法学会安全感。因此，我们需要做一系列其它事情，让患者处于正确的心理状态，去重新体验世界并感到安全。我们帮助人们减少担忧，帮助他们改善睡眠，建立自信，然后当我们让患者达到最佳心理状态时，我们再进行这种对世界安全感的直接学习。这会建立起一种更占主导地位的“世界是安全的”观点。这种方法中需要知道的一个重要点是，我们在治疗中并不真正去告诉患者他们错了，或者挑战他们现有的立场。我们只是提出了另一种关于正在发生的事情的描述。
And then we challenge that and let's see whether that's right. And we help the person through direct experience. So we try and do less sitting in a room talking much more. Well, let's go to the cafe or walk down the street or give you chances to find out directly how the world is now. And of course, some of the people, you know, the past was difficult. And of course, we don't know what went on then, but we can find out how things are now. So as well, if we do it over six months, it's a sort of face-to-face therapy, but we've recently developed and are currently testing a guided online program that puts all of this an online program and there's also weekly contact with their mental health professional
然后我们挑战它，看看它是否正确。我们通过直接体验来帮助患者。所以我们尽量减少坐在房间里谈话，更多地去咖啡馆、走在街上，或者给你机会直接了解世界现在的样子。当然，对有些人来说，过去确实很困难。我们当然不知道那时发生了什么，但我们可以了解现在的情况。所以，如果我们在六个月内完成，这是一种面对面的治疗，但我们最近开发并正在测试一种引导式在线程序，它将所有这些内容整合到一个在线程序中，并且每周与他们的心理健康专业人员进行联系，
trained in this approach too. So we're trying to find ways to scale this approach because our outcomes are really good and are what I hoped for when I kind of set up in this journey to develop it. So it's a treatment based upon a really good understanding of paranoia, and that's important because you need to understand the person's position, these thoughts haven't come out of nowhere. The people have thought long and hard to form these beliefs, and we need to understand their perspective, but also set out an alternative counterweight or counterweight that set out a journey they could try to see whether actually that might give a different view of
他们也接受过这种方法的培训。所以我们正在尝试寻找扩展这种方法的方法，因为我们的疗效非常好，这正是我在开启这段旅程并开发它时所希望的。所以这是一种基于对偏执的深刻理解的治疗，这一点很重要，因为你需要理解患者的立场，这些想法并非凭空而来。人们经过深思熟虑才形成了这些信念，我们需要理解他们的视角，同时也设定一个替代的平衡点，让他们尝试看看这是否能为他们提供一种不同的
the world for them now. Is drug therapy generally associated with this kind of treatment? Yeah, so most people I work with are people who are diagnosed with things like schizophrenia, and they all typically be on antipsychotic medication. And my team is normally seeing people who haven't fully responded to standard treatments. So the medication either hasn't worked enough or perhaps hasn't worked for that person. There's certainly evidence that medications can help. But antipsychotics are certainly people of psychosis are really the main line of treatments provided,
看待世界的方式。药物治疗通常与这种治疗结合使用吗？是的，我合作的大多数人都是被诊断患有精神分裂症等疾病的人，他们通常都在服用抗精神病药物。我的团队通常接待的是那些对标准治疗没有完全反应的患者。所以药物要么效果不够，要么可能对那个人无效。当然有证据表明药物可以提供帮助。但抗精神病药物确实是精神病患者的主要治疗手段，
but there is good evidence that adding psychological therapy helps, and the former psychological therapy feeling safe that we developed looks to be really good at helping a lot of people. So we often can get recovery in persecuted illusions with our psychological treatment. Having said that, there's still a proportion of people who don't benefit for what we do. So there have been a huge advances in understanding psychologically paranoia, and that's lit a better treatment, but there's still much more to learn about it, and there's still improvements we can do in the treatments.
但有充分证据表明，增加心理治疗是有帮助的。我们开发的“感觉安全”心理治疗方法在帮助许多人方面看起来非常有效。所以我们通常可以通过我们的心理治疗实现被害妄想的康复。话虽如此，仍有一部分人无法从我们的工作中受益。因此，在理解偏执的心理学方面已经取得了巨大的进步，这带来了更好的治疗方法，但关于它还有很多需要学习的地方，我们的治疗方法仍有改进空间。
You've been using virtual reality in your treatment program for quite a few years. How does that work? Why is it such a useful tool for treating paranoia? Yeah, I first used it. It was about 25 years ago, and that's because there's a real issue in paranoia, which really sort of touched upon at the beginning in the sense, is that there are real dangers in the world, and sometimes you don't know whether someone's being paranoid or telling you about genuine threat in the environment, and it's important that we don't close our ears to the fact that some of our patients may be getting also some hostile behaviour from other people. So I use virtuality to, as an assessment talk, first of all, to present people with neutral social situations with computer characters that were programmed to be neutral. And then we knew that people were seeing hostility from these characters.
您在治疗计划中使用虚拟现实（VR）已经好几年了。它是如何运作的？为什么它是治疗偏执的有用工具？是的，我第一次使用它是在大约 25 年前，这是因为偏执中存在一个真正的问题，我在开头确实触及到了这一点，即世界上确实存在真正的危险，有时你不知道某人是偏执还是在告诉你环境中存在的真实威胁，重要的是我们不能对某些患者可能确实受到他人敌意行为的事实充耳不闻。所以我首先使用虚拟现实作为评估工具，向人们展示中性的社交场景，其中的计算机角色被编程为中性的。然后我们知道人们从这些角色中看到了敌意。
That was genuine paranoia. So firstly, I use it to assess paranoia and then use it to also work on the understanding that underpins the treatment. But increasingly what we've done is use virtual reality to present a whole range of social situations for the person to learn safety in those situations. And of course, you might say, well, they know it's not a real situation, so doesn't that actually mean they don't learn anything? But that's the beauty of VR. Your body and your mind basically acts if it's real, even if your consciousness is telling
那才是真正的偏执。所以首先，我用它来评估偏执，然后也用它来研究治疗背后的理解。但我们越来越多地使用虚拟现实来呈现一系列社交场景，让患者在这些场景中学习安全感。当然，你可能会说，他们知道这不是真实的情况，所以这难道不意味着他们学不到任何东西吗？但这就是 VR 的魅力所在。即使你的意识告诉你
you that actually it's not a real situation. So if actually you learn the virtual character to safe, that learning transfers into the real world and we've certainly got evidence that if you try these sorts of practices in VR, you can get real changes in paranoia in day-to-day life. And in some ways, it's easier for people to tolerate the VR treatment because of this awareness, it's not real. It actually gives you enough psychological safety for the brain to take in new information. So that's been a very intriguing strand of our work. And one thing, we rather like our online program, there's a potential that you automate treatment provision within VR.
这不是真实的情况，你的身体和大脑基本上也会表现得好像它是真实的一样。所以如果你在虚拟现实中学会了虚拟角色是安全的，这种学习就会转移到现实世界中。我们确实有证据表明，如果你在 VR 中尝试这些练习，你可以在日常生活中获得偏执的真正改变。在某些方面，人们更容易忍受 VR 治疗，因为他们意识到这不是真的。它实际上给了大脑足够的心理安全感来吸收新信息。所以这是我们工作中非常引人入胜的一条主线。还有一点，我们相当喜欢我们的在线程序，在 VR 中自动化提供治疗是有潜力的。
And of course, in VR, you can present stimuli in ways that you can't in the real world that could be therapeutically helpful. So, yeah, that's been both a way to assess but also understand but also treat paranoia. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. and entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove
当然，在 VR 中，你可以以现实世界中无法实现的方式呈现刺激，这在治疗上可能是有帮助的。所以，是的，这既是一种评估方式，也是一种理解和治疗偏执的方式。您的夏天从家得宝（The Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日促销开始。是时候用 Next Grill 四头燃气烧烤炉开启夏季烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元。整个季节都可以用 Hampton Bay West Grove
seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th U.S. only exclusions apply, see Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water.
七件套户外餐桌椅套装来招待客人，仅需 499 美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，适用排除条款，详情请参阅 Home Depot.com/price-match。你说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。
We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost. Or you could book a lot. stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton for the stay. What might a typical VR scenario
我们只是还没找到那几步路。我们省了多少钱？足够了。足够去迷失自我了。或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店的住宿。欢迎来到您的海滨客房。距离水边仅几步之遥。希尔顿促销活动现已开启。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可享 8 折优惠，获得您期待的住宿体验。当您想要节省开支而不是意外时，住哪里很重要。希尔顿，为您提供理想住宿。典型的 VR 场景可能
look like if I were trying to imagine putting on the headset, what would I be seeing? Yeah, so the most obvious things that we would do might put people into getting onto a bus, going into a shop, being a shopping centre, or also practicing walking out the front door, because some of our patients are even getting out of the street is difficult. And there'll be different levels of difficulty. So initially there may be no people in these scenarios, and sometimes we'll introduce a few people, a great number of people, and perhaps in this scenarios the person has to do something where they almost turn their back on people
是什么样子的？如果我试着想象戴上耳机，我会看到什么？是的，我们做的最明显的事情可能是让人们坐上公共汽车、走进商店、身处购物中心，或者练习走出前门，因为我们的一些患者连走出街道都很困难。会有不同难度的级别。所以最初这些场景中可能没有人，有时我们会引入几个人，大量的人，也许在这些场景中，患者必须做一些几乎背对人们的事情，
to make themselves a bit more vulnerable at front of the virtual characters, always set up some games within it where, for example, in a cafe scene, suddenly a child will be blowing sort of bubbles and you have to go and catch them, which means you have to get very near people, and everyone then turns and looks at you, so really the sense of attention. So there are very simple ways to enable people to be in a social setting, to be at the center of the social settings that all eyes are on them,
让自己在虚拟角色面前变得稍微脆弱一点，总是会在其中设置一些游戏，例如，在咖啡馆场景中，突然一个孩子会吹泡泡，你必须去抓住它们，这意味着你必须非常靠近人们，然后每个人都会转过身看着你，所以这确实是一种被关注的感觉。所以有非常简单的方法可以让人们处于社交环境中，处于社交环境的中心，所有的目光都集中在他们身上，
and to learn that they're okay, they can cope and they're safe. So that's one direct way, but we're also looking at other ways to use to help people build up their self-confidence, so they then feel less vulnerable, for example. So there's a whole range of those other sorts of facts, as I mentioned in paranoia, that potentially you could use VR to help provide all these sort of counterweights to the more mistrustful way of viewing the world. Is there a particular point in the lifespan when paranoia begins to manifest itself? And I'm asking this because I'm thinking about parents who might be listening to this and thinking, wow, I mean, is there something I should be looking for in my kids or does paranoia
并学习到他们没问题，他们可以应对，他们是安全的。这是直接的一种方式，但我们也在寻找其它方法来帮助人们建立自信，这样他们就不会感到那么脆弱。所以，正如我提到的偏执中的其它因素一样，有一系列因素，你可能可以使用 VR 来帮助提供所有这些对抗不信任世界观的平衡点。偏执在生命周期的某个特定点开始显现吗？我问这个问题是因为我在想那些可能正在收听节目的父母，他们可能会想，哇，我应该在孩子身上寻找什么吗？还是偏执
really not manifest until adulthood? I think there's an awareness and a decision-making process. I think in the early teens, really, when people are becoming more independent and more aware of threats in the world. And I think that's developmentally appropriate. That's when you're beginning to think about what's safe, what isn't, and you're probably experiencing some bad behaviors from your peers and around you, and there might be bullying and stuff. So actually, there is a normal process of weighing it up. And during that, of course, sometimes people may get a little bit more mistrustful. I mean, you wouldn't want to pathologize it at this point. I think it's a normal process. And it comes out as exactly said at the beginning, it's something that one does have
真的要到成年才会显现？我认为这有一个意识和决策过程。我认为在十几岁早期，当人们变得更加独立并更加意识到世界上的威胁时。我认为这在发育上是适当的。那时你开始思考什么是安全的，什么不是，你可能正在经历同龄人和周围人的一些不良行为，可能会有欺凌之类的事情。所以实际上，有一个正常的权衡过程。在此期间，当然，有时人们可能会变得稍微多疑一点。我的意思是，你不会想在这一点上将其病理化。我认为这是一个正常的过程。正如我开头所说，这是一个人必须
to bear attention to because there are real threats in the world, and you've got to find the right balance. And those are typically happening from our research when people are reaching a little bit more independence in their world. So it actually arises early. And paranoia actually is highest levels in adolescence and early adulthood. It actually comes down over time. And then perhaps there's a little bit more of an increase later on when people are quite a bit older. And sometimes that may be related. Certainly things like a dementia, there's going to be a little bit more paranoia. And actually sometimes when people have hearing loss, that can raise mistrust as well. Does using marijuana or other drugs put people at higher risk for paranoid thoughts? How does
注意的事情，因为世界上确实存在真正的威胁，你必须找到正确的平衡。根据我们的研究，当人们在世界上获得更多独立性时，这种情况通常会发生。所以它实际上出现得很早。偏执在青春期和成年早期确实处于最高水平。它实际上会随着时间的推移而下降。然后也许在人们年纪大得多的时候会有所增加。有时这可能与此有关。当然，像痴呆症这样的事情，偏执会多一点。实际上，有时当人们有听力损失时，这也会增加不信任感。使用大麻或其它药物会使人们患偏执想法的风险更高吗？物质使用如何
substance use interact with paranoia? with acute intoxication of some illicit drugs, paranoia goes up and people will tell you that. That's pretty clear. And for a smaller percentage of people, that may continue for a bit longer after the drug has actually left the bloodstream. It is more likely to cause problems, the more you take and the early age of exposure to it. So that increases the risk that actually leads to a severe and more persisting problem outside the acute intoxication of the drug. And of course, it depends what the substance is and how strong it is. So there's a clear link, but also clearly it's not enough for its own because lots of people
与偏执相互作用？在急性摄入某些非法药物时，偏执感会上升，人们会告诉你这一点。这很清楚。对于一小部分人来说，这种情况在药物离开血液后可能会持续更久。你摄入的越多，接触的年龄越早，就越有可能导致问题。所以这增加了导致急性药物中毒之外的严重且更持久问题的风险。当然，这取决于物质是什么以及它的强度。所以有一个明确的联系，但显然它本身并不足以导致偏执，因为很多人
take these sorts of substances and don't get these consequences, but it's going to raise the risk. That's clear. It's true for cannabis, certainly, but also I think there's a connection with alcohol use as well, and that's going to raise the risk. But again, of course, lots of people are consuming alcohol without these consequences because of paranoia. There is a multiple things coming together that can vary in individual case, but these things do raise the risk. Did the COVID pandemic have an impact on the prevalence of paranoia?
使用这些物质并没有产生这些后果，但它会增加风险。这一点很清楚。大麻肯定如此，但我认为酒精使用也存在联系，这也会增加风险。但同样，当然，很多人在饮酒时并没有产生这些偏执的后果。有多种因素共同作用，在个体案例中会有所不同，但这些事情确实会增加风险。新冠疫情对偏执的流行有影响吗？
I mean, for a while there, we were all afraid of everything. Yes, I mean, I don't have good day to this. And it's always hard at the historical level because you don't have the nationally represented samples that are done over time. I mean, I think clearly for a period, anxiety went up. I mean, what was clear, I think, is that conspiracy beliefs are more general and mistrustful view of the world when mainstream at those times for lots of of reasons. Obviously, a lot of time to oneself and on the internet, everyday life had been transformed at that time. So I think at that time is certainly one of the indicators, at least to me, a lot of conspiracy stuff went mainstream. Conspiracy beliefs are different from paranoia.
我的意思是，有一段时间，我们都害怕一切。是的，我的意思是，我没有这方面的好数据。而且在历史层面上总是很难，因为你没有随时间推移而进行的全国代表性样本。我的意思是，我认为很明显有一段时间，焦虑感上升了。我认为很清楚的是，阴谋论在当时由于各种原因变得更加普遍，对世界的不信任感也随之增加。显然，很多时间是一个人待着，在互联网上，日常生活在那个时候发生了改变。所以我认为在那个时候，至少对我来说，很多阴谋论确实成为了主流。阴谋论与偏执是不同的。
There's obviously an overlap of general form of mistrust. In paranoia, you believe you're targeted and pretty much you're the only one. Conspiracy beliefs, that's not the case. It's a belief about some effect to a large number of people. So they share some causes, but there's also differences in those two. So at an individual level for the patients, say with psychosis I met, I think the pandemic at the time had different effects of different people. For some people, actually, when they're outside, there was more space from other people because you had to distance and the world became a little easier to navigate. For some people, that probably did ramp up fears a bit. What is the relationship between paranoia and physical illness? There's some overlap,
显然，它们在一般的不信任形式上有重叠。在偏执中，你认为自己是被针对的目标，而且几乎认为你是唯一的一个。阴谋论则不然。这是一种关于对大量人群产生某种影响的信念。所以它们共享一些原因，但这两者之间也存在差异。所以对于我遇到的精神病患者等个体层面，我认为当时的疫情对不同的人产生了不同的影响。对一些人来说，实际上，当他们在外面时，由于必须保持距离，与他人的空间更多了，世界变得更容易导航。对一些人来说，这可能确实加剧了恐惧。偏执与身体疾病之间有什么关系？有一些重叠，
And certainly for patients, I see you with psychosis, if the withdrawal and the isolation is bad for your physical health. And also there's some conditions and pain, for example, it's going to affect your sleep, which is going to affect your mood, which is going to link to mistrust. So again, it can contribute to make things worse. And then, of course, there are, as I mentioned before, things like dementia later that also is likely to bring on mistrust too. What got you interested in studying this aspect of mental illness? I mean, I think you alluded earlier to the fact that it was really seen as something that wasn't treatable years ago. And now it is partly through the work that you're doing.
当然，对于我看到的精神病患者，如果退缩和孤立对你的身体健康不利。而且还有一些疾病和疼痛，例如，它会影响你的睡眠，进而影响你的情绪，这会与不信任感联系起来。所以同样，它可能导致情况恶化。然后，当然，正如我之前提到的，还有像晚年痴呆症这样的事情，也可能会带来不信任感。是什么让您对研究心理疾病的这一方面感兴趣？我的意思是，我想您之前提到过，多年前它确实被视为一种无法治疗的东西。而现在，部分归功于您所做的工作，它变得可以治疗了。
But what was so intriguing to you about this particular issue? Yeah, so I remember at university, being talked about psychosis and these sorts of problems and the traditional view that actually wasn't much psychology to it is ununderstandable. That was the dominant view and their psychological treatments, weren't, well, they weren't recommended at that point. And for me, I remember very vividly just meeting the first patient diagnosed with psychosis. And it had to be a home visit because they wouldn't come up at their house because they were worried about governments of various agencies who are going to kidnap them and torture them. And to be a home visit. And also,
但这个特定问题有什么让您如此着迷的？是的，我记得在大学里，谈论精神病和这些问题时，传统的观点是实际上没有太多心理学内容，它是不可理解的。那是占主导地位的观点，当时的心理治疗并不被推荐。对我来说，我非常生动地记得第一次见到被诊断为精神病的患者。那必须是一次家访，因为他们不会走出家门，因为他们担心各种机构的政府人员会绑架并折磨他们。必须进行家访。而且，
I was told, don't knock on the door. They went answer. I had to go through to side window, tap on that three times. And Robert let me in. And we talked for an hour. And, you know, was so clear on the basis of things that happened to him in his past, why he would be so wary of other people. He'd become basically agoraphobic, had left the house. So in fact, you know, although he was fearing all these bad things, he was never really being outside to find out that actually he was going to be okay. And I could see so many connections with anxiety that for me, the routine was, at least initially, to view this as having a very large contribution of anxiety. He was very fearful of the world. He had a very strong, what we call a threat belief, which is typical of anxiety disorders.
我被告知，不要敲门。他们不会回答。我必须走到侧窗，在上面敲三下。罗伯特让我进去了。我们谈了一个小时。而且，你知道，基于他过去发生的事情，他为什么会对他人如此警惕，这非常清楚。他基本上变得有广场恐惧症，离开了房子。所以事实上，你知道，尽管他害怕所有这些坏事，但他从未真正去外面发现实际上他会没事的。我可以看到与焦虑的许多联系，所以对我来说，最初的常规是将此视为焦虑有很大贡献。他非常害怕世界。他有一种非常强烈的、我们称之为威胁信念的东西，这是焦虑症的典型特征。
He was worrying. He was anticipating harm. And he was putting up the defenses so that actually he was protecting his fears. So for me, it was the root in the first research I did. Actually, the first research I did was, I measured levels of worry, people with severe paranoia and found they were very high. And that sounds unsurprising. But actually, that was the first time anyone had measured levels of worry in people with psychosis, because it was thought that worry was a problem of anxiety depression, psychosis, something completely different. So people didn't even measure levels of worry in our patient. But of course, if you do have worry and you have some fears, this is going to make everything worse. It elaborates the content, it bringing images to mind, mix it, you
他在担忧。他在预料伤害。他竖起了防御，以至于他实际上是在保护他的恐惧。所以对我来说，这是我所做的第一项研究的根源。实际上，我做的第一项研究是，我测量了严重偏执患者的担忧水平，发现它们非常高。这听起来并不令人惊讶。但实际上，这是第一次有人测量精神病患者的担忧水平，因为人们认为担忧是焦虑抑郁的问题，精神病是完全不同的东西。所以人们甚至没有测量我们患者的担忧水平。但当然，如果你有担忧并且有一些恐惧，这会让一切变得更糟。它阐述了内容，它将图像带入脑海，混合它，它
play on your mind all the time. So worry was one. Another one I've done a lot of research on her out, which I didn't even mention yet, is that poor sleep. And again, it was ignored in our clients. Everyone was kind of aware our patients didn't sleep very well. It was just thought, well, that's the consequence of it all. But actually, and again, it's not really surprising. if you sleep badly, it makes you anxious, it makes you more miserable and affects your judgments of the world. So do a lot of work now treating sleep problems in people with psychosis. We can definitely treat the sleep problems and that brings down the heat of the situation is lessens the paranoia to a degree. It's not the only thing, just like worry isn't the only thing,
一直萦绕在你的心头。所以担忧是一个。我做了很多研究的另一个是，我还没提到的，是睡眠不足。同样，它在我们的客户中被忽视了。每个人都知道我们的患者睡得不好。人们只是认为，好吧，那是这一切的结果。但实际上，而且同样，这并不令人惊讶。如果你睡得不好，它会让你焦虑，让你更痛苦，并影响你对世界的判断。所以我现在做了很多工作来治疗精神病患者的睡眠问题。我们绝对可以治疗睡眠问题，这会降低情况的温度，在一定程度上减轻偏执。这不是唯一的事情，就像担忧不是唯一的事情一样，
but you could do a whole range of things to calm the temperature down a little bit and enable the person to then think and you and then find out and you how the world is now. For people who might be on the border line where they're anxious and they worry a lot and maybe they're in danger of falling into a level of early paranoia, what can they do to prevent it? Are there any sort of mental exercises, things that you would recommend that people could do to ward off and maybe to stop the rumination that makes everything worse? Yeah. I think there's some, I mean, these cut across most mental health conditions, really. I think it's pay attention to sleep. It is about reducing worry and it probably is building up self-confidence.
但你可以做一系列事情来稍微降低温度，使患者能够重新思考，并重新发现世界现在的样子。对于那些可能处于边缘，感到焦虑并担心很多，也许有陷入早期偏执水平危险的人，他们能做些什么来预防它？有没有什么心理练习，您会建议人们做些什么来抵御并可能停止使一切变得更糟的反刍思维？是的。我认为有一些，我的意思是，这些确实跨越了大多数心理健康状况。我认为是注意睡眠。这是关于减少担忧，并且可能是在建立自信。
Those are three big ones. The worry stuff really, I mean, it's a very understand people worry when they feel frightened because they feel worry protects people, keeps them safe. And really actually worry just skews the worldview. And it's much better to limit the amount of time worry, perhaps using problem solving. But most importantly, and again, this is crucial, just making sure you're doing meaningful activity that you have less time on your own ruminating because that's not good for any of us.
这是三大要素。担忧的事情，我的意思是，当人们感到害怕时，他们会担忧，这是非常可以理解的，因为他们觉得担忧可以保护人们，让他们保持安全。实际上，担忧只会扭曲世界观。限制担忧的时间，也许使用问题解决法，要好得多。但最重要的是，这一点至关重要，确保你正在进行有意义的活动，这样你独自反刍的时间就会减少，因为这对我们任何人都不好。
So if you can try and share your ideas with someone you trust so you're able to speak them aloud rather than having to turn them in your head all the time, we just write them down just to get them stopping for them and sort of rolling around in your mind and spending too much time on them, get engaged in factivity, try and get good sleep. Also just try and actually go back to all the good qualities we have and make sure we're putting them in action.
所以如果你能尝试与你信任的人分享你的想法，这样你就能大声说出来，而不是一直把它放在脑子里，我们只是把它们写下来，让它们停止在你的脑海中翻滚，不要花太多时间在上面，参与活动，尝试获得良好的睡眠。还要尝试真正回到我们拥有的所有优秀品质，并确保我们将它们付诸行动。
So, I mean, and I think those things are good across mental health conditions, really. Try not to spend too much time in your thoughts, certainly not in the nighttime in the early hours, which often we all do, but that's just not a good way to solve things. If you really want to worry, fine, but just keep it to a much smaller portion of your day. Problem solving is better, and what's even better is actually really being engaged in stuff that is meaningful and purposeful for you. For people who have a clinical level of paranoia, is there any self-awareness that maybe what they're thinking is unrealistic? I mean, is there some way of getting people to
我的意思是，我认为这些方法对各种心理健康状况都很有帮助。尽量不要花太多时间沉溺于自己的思绪中，尤其是在深夜或凌晨，虽然我们经常会这样做，但这并不是解决问题的良策。如果你真的想担忧，没问题，但请将其限制在一天中很小的一部分时间里。解决问题会更好，而更好的是真正投入到对你有意义和目标的事情中去。对于患有临床偏执症的人来说，他们是否会有自我意识，意识到自己的想法可能是不现实的？我的意思是，有没有什么方法能让人们
understand that, no, everybody is not looking at you, the world is not out to get you? Yes. I mean, I think clinically it varies. So for some people, what we call the degree of convection in the beliefs, how strongly they believe it? We might say, how strong you do believe it to not 100%. Not a percent I don't believe at 100%. I believe it absolutely. Some of our patients, it might be around 50 or 60 percent, but go up in particular moment. But some patients who will sell, they'll say, I believe a thousand percent. And we can certainly get really good outcomes of the treatment, even if people have no awareness. But plenty of people do have an awareness, even at the high extent that it's dominating their lives too much,
明白这一点，即并不是每个人都在盯着你看，世界也不是在针对你？是的。我的意思是，我认为在临床上情况各异。对于一些人来说，我们称之为信念的坚定程度，即他们相信的程度有多深？我们可能会问，你相信它的程度有多强，不是100%吗？不是百分之百，我不相信是100%。我绝对相信。我们的一些病人，这个比例可能在50%或60%左右，但在特定时刻会上升。但有些病人会说，我相信是一千个百分点。即使人们没有这种意识，我们当然也能获得非常好的治疗效果。但很多人确实有这种意识，即使在很大程度上，这种意识也过多地主导了他们的生活，
that this is taking up too much headspace. And the way in for our treatment is really sometimes just recognizing this is tough. It's taking up all your headspace. You're not thinking about all those other things you'd like to be doing in life. And it's making you anxious and you're not sleeping so well. So maybe we can work on that a little bit. And then as we work with people, we might then do exercise. is, you know, is it better to stay in your room while we're in, let's try that for a few hours,
这占据了太多的心理空间。我们治疗的切入点有时仅仅是承认这很艰难。它占据了你所有的心理空间。你没有去思考生活中其他你想做的事情。这让你感到焦虑，而且你睡得也不太好。所以也许我们可以稍微改善一下。当我们与人们一起工作时，我们可能会进行练习，你知道，待在房间里更好，还是我们试着出去几个小时，
or go out for a walk. So we test that out and see which is better. And while we're not making a big song and dance about that stage, the person while they're out on a walk might go, that was quite nice that walk. And I saw some people, and it was okay. So you're allowing the person to have some experiences a bit more positive. And later on, we'll, we do make that very clear. We're looking at the signs of safety and we're trying to work out where the safety is in the world now. but there's lots of lots of things we could do. But clearly for some people, there are difficulties engaging with help, and that's half for the person, but also half for the people around them
或者出去散散步。所以我们测试一下，看看哪种更好。虽然我们没有大张旗鼓地对待这个阶段，但当那个人在散步时，可能会觉得，那次散步还不错。我看到了一些人，感觉还可以。所以你是在让那个人获得一些更积极的体验。稍后，我们会非常明确地指出这一点。我们正在寻找安全的迹象，并试图找出世界上哪里是安全的。但我们可以做的事情还有很多。但显然，对于一些人来说，寻求帮助存在困难，这既是当事人的问题，也是他们身边人的问题，
who would like them to talk to someone and get help, and that really can be difficult. But for us, generally, it would be less saying going get help for your paranoia, because that may not go down so well as a label. And often the words we're using and worries about other people, but we might be saying, well, these are having effects on the things you do, on your mood, relationships,
他们希望当事人能找人谈谈并寻求帮助，这确实很困难。但对我们来说，通常不会说去为你的偏执寻求帮助，因为作为一个标签，这可能不太容易被接受。我们通常使用的词汇是关于对他人的担忧，但我们可能会说，这些担忧正在影响你的行为、情绪和人际关系，
so maybe that's worth checking in with someone about. So what are you working on now? What are the big questions you're still trying to answer? Oh, lots of things. Lots of things. We're doing a very large study
所以也许值得找人聊聊。那么你现在在研究什么？你还在试图回答哪些重大问题？哦，很多事情。很多事情。我们正在进行一项非常大规模的研究，
treating sleep problems in patients with severe mental problems, this idea that we can improve sleep a lot, that's great in the cell, but also that will less problems like paranoia. We're doing another large clinical trial testing,
治疗严重心理问题患者的睡眠障碍，这个想法是我们可以在很大程度上改善睡眠，这本身就很棒，而且也会减少偏执等问题。我们正在进行另一项大型临床试验，测试，
feeling safer, which is our guided online program, which is basically putting our really good face-to-face therapy into guided form online. So that's about accessibility. We're doing some VR work, treating low self-esteem in people with psychosis. Basically, my team does a lot of work. We do a lot of work trying to develop the understanding of problems like paranoia, using that knowledge to develop better treatments and then trialing it. And then also work around getting it out there into services,
“感觉更安全”（Feeling Safer），这是我们的在线指导项目，基本上是将我们非常好的面对面治疗转化为在线指导形式。所以这关乎可及性。我们正在做一些虚拟现实（VR）工作，治疗精神病患者的低自尊。基本上，我的团队做了很多工作。我们做了大量工作，试图加深对偏执等问题的理解，利用这些知识开发更好的治疗方法，然后进行试验。此外，还有关于将其推广到服务中的工作，
someone that is in training or some of it is in models of delivery that actually perhaps rely, less on a therapist but more on the person having more control. What is always learning, you know, we're evolving people with who've had or have severe paranoia in our research and they contribute a lot to working out what's important to research and how to do it. So we have a lot of lived experience advisors. It improves the quality of our work and the purpose of it. So we're focused really and trying to develop really good psychological therapies and get them out there. And there's lots of work to be done on that.
有些是在培训中，有些是在交付模式中，这些模式可能较少依赖治疗师，而更多地依赖于让当事人拥有更多的控制权。什么是永远在学习的，你知道，我们正在发展，在我们的研究中，我们让那些曾经或现在患有严重偏执症的人参与进来，他们为确定研究重点以及如何进行研究做出了很大贡献。所以我们有很多有生活经验的顾问。这提高了我们工作的质量和目的。因此，我们真正专注于尝试开发非常好的心理疗法并将其推广出去。在这方面还有很多工作要做。
Dr. Freeman, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been really interesting. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. For those of you who want to know more about psychology and the work of the American Psychological Association, you can join us as a supporter. You don't have to be a psychologist. The benefits include a subscription to our award-winning magazine, monitor on psychology, as well as discounts on books and other publications. So psychology is your passion, or if you just want to know more about the science,
弗里曼博士，我想感谢你今天加入我的节目。这真的非常有趣。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）之前的剧集。如果你喜欢你所听到的内容，请订阅并给我们留下评论。对于那些想了解更多关于心理学和美国心理学会工作的人，你可以加入我们成为支持者。你不必是心理学家。福利包括订阅我们屡获殊荣的杂志《心理学监测》（Monitor on Psychology），以及书籍和其他出版物的折扣。所以，如果心理学是你的热情所在，或者如果你只是想了解更多关于这门科学的知识，
you can become a supporter by visiting at.ap.a.org slash speaking. That's at.a.a.org slash speaking. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Thank you for listening. The American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. Relax and let Ralph's delivery handle your grocery shopping this week.
你可以通过访问 at.apa.org/speaking 成为支持者。网址是 at.apa.org/speaking。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼（Lee Winerman）制作。感谢收听。美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。放松一下，让 Ralph's 的配送服务帮你处理本周的杂货采购吧。
We start with only the freshest items, then review your list and carefully choose each one. Then we pack it all up and deliver it in as little as 30 minutes, so you can feel confident it's what you ordered. Fresh groceries, your way, with Ralph's delivery and pickup. And right now, you can save $20 on your first delivery. or pick-up order. Ralph's, fresh for everyone. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们从最新鲜的商品开始，然后查看你的清单并仔细挑选每一件。接着，我们将所有商品打包，并在短短30分钟内送达，这样你就可以确信这就是你订购的商品。通过 Ralph's 的配送和自提服务，以你的方式获取新鲜杂货。现在，你的首次配送或自提订单可节省20美元。Ralph's，为每个人提供新鲜。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。